dans la commune de château fort sur les
terres du domaine dorce rasé en 1951
ce moulin vient de se voir attribuer le
label de patrimoine d'intérêt régional
si dans le sud-ouest des yvelines près
de la rivière de la mérantaise que se
tient ce moule en chargé d'histoire on a
retrouvé des traces écrites de
l'existence ce moulin à partir de 751 il
ya une première reproduction du moulin
sur des
une carte de 10 702 et le à partir de ce
moment-là différentes cartes le
reproduisent donc on sait que ce moulin
voilà existe depuis la fin du xviie
siècle et nous a été transmis jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
parmi les 88 moulin de la région le
moulin d'or ce serait selon les
spécialistes
l'un des mieux conservés ce label de
patrimoine d'intérêt régional créé en
2018 par la région ile de france
pourrait apporter un coup de projecteur
pour le moulin ce label permet de
reconnaître un peu ses qualités de
moulins et donc de pouvoir le valoriser
et de l'identifier comme tel et de le
préserver aussi sur le long terme
et puis ce qu'on espère
le label permet ensuite de postuler pour
avoir des aides supplémentaires pour
valoriser vous restaurer et notre projet
ce serait de pouvoir restaurer la roue
et la remettre en état
un label qui permettrait aux lauréats de
bénéficier d'une aide à hauteur de 30
mille euros pour la valorisation du site
et de 500000 euros pour les travaux de
rénovation
le chantier du moulin d'or ce pourrait
débuter d'ici 2022